[Applauso]
[Musica]
questo sono io ma al momento un
infortunio alla schiena piuttosto
significativo non mi permette di ballare
infortuni purtroppo sono una delle
complicazioni nella vita di un ballerino
e sono proprio i momenti come questo che
ti portano a mettere in discussione le
tue scelte
non si finisce effettivamente mai di
confrontarsi con dubbi e debolezze non
solo psicologiche ma come in questo caso
proprio anche fisiche ballare è sempre
stata una parte di me davvero non credo
di ricordare un giorno da bambino
passato senza danza o comunque in
qualche modo movimento
ho poi iniziato i miei studi di danza
classica proprio qui a piacenza circa 10
anni e da subito ho capito che in me
stava nascendo una vera e propria
passione anche le mie insegnanti hanno
subito riconosciuto delle qualità
diciamo necessarie per intraprendere
questa strada e quindi da subito mi
hanno spinto verso con corsi e stage
prima a livello nazionale ma dopo poco
anche internazionale proprio finita la
terza media dopo aver vinto il mio primo
concorso internazionale sono partito per
amburgo in germania sono partito con
molta motivazione molto entusiasmo
avevo appunto poco più di 13 anni e
quindi non avevo ancora bene messo a
fuoco quello che mi stava capitando
quanto drastico questo cambiamento
sarebbe stato e tutti i sacrifici che la
mia scelta comunque comportava è stato
poi solo quando sono entrato in
quell'inter nato che ho davvero
realizzato che quella adesso sarebbe
stata la mia vita che quindi avrei
dovuto lasciare indietro una situazione
in cui mi sentivo sicuro e felice
spingermi oltre questa mia zona di
comfort
avrei dovuto iniziare un recente desco
quindi imparare una nuova lingua a
crearmi un nuovo gruppo di amici e anche
abituarmi un po questa nuova cultura
quindi questa mia adolescenza sarebbe
stato probabilmente più impegnativa più
dura probabilmente priva di quella
spensieratezza di quella leggerezza che
sono tipiche di quell'età
quello che però davvero mi spaventava in
assoluto di più di tutto era dovere
dovremo abituare una vita lontano dalla
mia famiglia dalla mia casa che fino a
quel momento comunque erano davvero
stato il mio tutto questa sensazione di
vuoto di tristezza mi ha portato per la
prima volta a un ritorno a me stesso a
un primo confronto con la mia
interiorità in quello spavento per la
prima volta ho capito di aver bisogno di
aiuto e che se davvero avesse ascoltato
le mie debolezze sarei riuscito a capire
che aveva una forza dentro che mi
avrebbe aiutato a superare questo
momento di difficoltà
penso che ci sia sempre dentro di noi
una forza una spinta qualcosa che ci fa
andare avanti se comunque il sogno non
si è spento e anche se si ha la fortuna
di avere qualcuno qui per parlare delle
proprie paure senza vergogna per me è
stata proprio la voce di mia madre mi
ricordo queste telefonate di sera al
telefono io in lacrime è lei che mi
ripeteva che questa brutta sensazione
sarebbe passata che mi ci sarei abituato
e alla quale io rispondevo dicendo che
non volevo abituarmi perché avrebbe
voluto avrebbe dovuto dire rimanere lì e
io non volevo io volevo tornare a casa
abbiamo insomma ha deciso di prenderla
tappe sarebbe passata una settimana poi
due poi un mese e se alla fine di questo
periodo non mi fosse abituato sarei
potuto tornare a casa senza problemi
questo mi ha davvero aiutato è così
passata una settimana due poi un mese
sono riuscito ad abituarmi
stavo imparando la lingua miur creato un
gruppo di amici comunque hanno anche
grandi soddisfazioni a lezioni di danza
e seguenti due anni ad amburgo sono
comunque un periodo che accordo davvero
con molta gioia
ecco che grazie a questo mio primo
ritorno a me stesso questo mio confronto
quella mia interiorità sono riuscito a
riconoscere la debolezza la fragilità di
questo momento ea trovare un po per
ritrovare la forza di questa mia
passione ma ancora vi vorrei dire di un
altro momento in cui mi sono trovato a
dover fare i conti con la mia scelta con
i miei dubbi con le mie debolezze è
stato quando ho partecipato ad uno dei
concorsi più importanti forse di danza
classica il della sun
da quando ero bambino che sognavo di
partecipare a uno di questi concorsi di
poter ballare su quel palcoscenico
guardavo video di ragazzi e non vedevo
l'ora di essere uno di loro
e finalmente toccava a me era la mia
chance di far vedere a tutti quello che
sapevo fare e vedere quello che avevo
imparato
quindi vi potete immaginare come mi sia
sentito quando hanno annunciato che non
ero passato alla finale della
competizione è stata davvero forse la
prima volta in cui ho dovuto fare i
conti con un fallimento fino ad allora
avevo avuto per lo più successi e
soddisfazioni 15 quindi questa
sensazione mi aveva davvero colto
impreparato non sapevo come reagire ci
ho messo del tempo e con fatica sono
riuscito ad ammettere a me stesso quello
che era successo che semplicemente non
ce l'avevo fatta che probabilmente
quindi non ero stato bravo abbastanza
diciamo che se chiedete a mio padre
ancora oggi vi dirà che è stato perché
ero infortunato ma io non penso che sia
andata proprio così a parte gli scherzi
c'è voluto davvero del tempo a non
cercare alibi che comunque sono sempre
pronti lì a disposizione ho dovuto
guardarmi dentro ho dovuto cercare di
capire che comunque non ero ancora
arrivato da nessuna parte che avevo
bisogno ancora di tanto lavoro che
questo mio percorso mi portava fino a
questo punto ma dovevo trovare qualcosa
dentro per andare avanti per mettermi
ancora alla prova e in questa sconfitta
proprio ho trovato la spinta per
spingermi verso il mio successivo salto
fare l'audizione per andare a studiare
al real ballet school di londra studiare
alla royal ballet school di londra è
ancora una volta un sogno che si
realizza
sognavo davvero di poter essere un
ragazzo che studiava in questa scuola a
londra così prestigiosa
ed ecco che ero lì però cavolo se ad
amburgo questo momento iniziale era
stato complicato qui a londra davvero
ancora di più
un altro cambiamento quindi ancora una
volta mi trovo a dover lasciare indietro
una situazione che ormai era diventata
familiare e comoda spingermi ancora una
volta oltre questa mia zona di confort
la scuola aveva un'impostazione
completamente diversa
era molto più distaccata molto più
rigida anche gli insegnanti erano molto
più freddi molto più esigenti tutti i
ragazzi che erano in corso con me erano
davvero ad un livello altissimo e quindi
anche gli orari che facevamo erano
cambiati erano molto più pesanti
iniziavamo alle otto e mezza con un paio
d'ore di scuola accademica e poi dalle
dieci e mezza alle sei e mezza era solo
danza solo prove allenamenti elezioni
passo a due di repertorio
quindi mi sono anche dovuto abituare ad
un altro tipo di stanchezza di
difficoltà non solo appunto più
psicologica ma adesso era anche fisica
mi ricordo che tornavo a casa da questi
allenamenti davvero spostato e stanco e
questa pressione questa competizione che
ci veniva posta davvero stava diventando
pesante per me da sopportare
ecco che ancora una volta mi trovo a
dover dubitare a delle mie scelte delle
mie capacità
per la prima volta però ho dubitato ho
dubitato della mia passione della mia
determinazione della mia voglia
nell'inseguire questo sogno
oddio ballare mi piaceva ancora
immensamente
e questo lo sapevo ma i momenti di
difficoltà i momenti di sacrificio
sembravano davvero prevalere su quelli
di gioia e di gratificazione quindi per
la prima volta mi sono davvero chiesto
se ne valesse la pena se questa vita da
ballerino alla fine la volesse davvero
con tutto me stesso
ci è voluto del tempo i tre anni che ho
passato a londra sono stati diciamo
accompagnati da questi sentimenti di
disorientamento
mi sono dovuto ascoltare davvero in
profondità con sincerità e autenticità e
sono arrivato a capire che in questa
fragilità
c'era anche una sensibilità doveva
essere consapevole di avere questa
sensibilità che non doveva penalizzarmi
ma anzi la potevo usare a mio vantaggio
diciamo che così facendo tra alti e
bassi sono riuscito comunque ad
impegnarmi a ottenere buoni risultati
perché comunque mi sono diplomato come
most outstanding radiohead del mio corso
e sono stato uno dei pochi i ragazzi
scelti per andrà a far parte del corpo
valve royal ballet fare parte del corpo
di ballo del real ballet ancora una
volta davvero un sogno che si realizza
eccoci qua sono tre anni che danza su
uno dei palcoscenici più prestigiosi del
mondo lavoro con colleghi artisti
davvero eccezionali casi di fama
mondiale
questo percorso mi ha portato fino a qui
mi ha portato fino a quello che so è
solo davvero un punto di partenza ne
sono consapevole è un punto di partenza
che però già mi consente uno sguardo
all'indietro
oltre alla disciplina alla dedizione e
all'impegno ea volte anche proprio al
solo senso del dovere
penso che sia stata questa forza
interiore questa passione che mi abbia
fatto trovare la forza di andare avanti
di superare ogni difficoltà provvisoria
tappa ce ne sono tantissime di
difficoltà in scelte di vita così
totalizzante e comunque in qualsiasi
percorso che ti porti a lasciare
indietro qualcosa di familiare e di
comodo
tutti noi ci troviamo davanti momenti di
questo tipo tutti i giorni a volte
queste difficoltà ci sembrano davvero
insormontabili
io penso che ci potrebbe aiutare e
cercare un obiettivo un evento futuro
qualcosa che ci motivi che ci dia la
carica per andare avanti e superarle ad
esempio io sono qui sono quattro mesi e
mezzo che non ballo che non posso
ballare per questo infortunio ma so che
tra due o tre mesi sarò di nuovo sul
palcoscenico del real ballet a ballare a
fare quello che davvero mi piace fare e
questo mi motiva mi dà la carica mi
spinge in avanti ho parlato parecchio di
questa forza interiore di questa spinta
in avanti e vi invito davvero a cercarla
sempre a cercarla rispettarla ed
ascoltarla
ma occorre anche però guardarsi dentro a
cercare di capirsi con sincerità
autenticità accettare le debolezze
accettare l'insicurezza il dubbio la
difficoltà è proprio dentro di sé che io
penso che si possa trovare una forza che
davvero non si sa di avere quindi questa
spinta in avanti va sempre accompagnata
però da un ritorno un ritorno a se
stessi
ritorno alla realtà un ritorno a
misurarsi con tutto quello che si ha la
fortuna di avere ma anche con tutto
quello che si sa ancora da superare
grazie
[Applauso]